hey what's up guys this is marcus
brownlee here from mkbhd and welcome to
another hd review video and this is
actually going to be
a sort of a tour of my youtube insight
which is uh basically the statistics of
the viewers of my youtube channel
so uh before i begin this video i'm
going to go to my channel page real
quick before i begin this video i want
to let you guys know that you can post a
video response to this one uh of your
own tour of your youtube insight i
really want to see what your youtube
insight looks like what your popular
videos are
where your viewers are from stuff like
that that's cool stuff to see
so basically the youtube insight if you
if you didn't know already is basically
the um the statistics of the viewers of
your channel and the viewers of your
videos you can view the youtube insight
for uh an individual video if it has a
lot of views and comments
and ratings or you could view the
insight for your entire channel and
that's actually what i prefer
so to do that when you're signed in just
go up to the right hand side and hit the
account button
and that'll bring up this account page
youtube.com account and from here you
can go hit that inside button on the
right hand side or just hover over
account on the left hand side and hit
insight statistics and data
and this will bring your youtube insight
which it does take a tiny bit of time to
load but it'll bring up your youtube
inside right here and this is the
summary page for your youtube insight
it'll tell you a very general overview
of the demographics of your audience so
if you're thinking about emailing a
company uh telling them you know i have
a lot of viewers from this part of the
world or i have a lot of uh subscribers
who like these types of videos you can
definitely check this part out
so here's the summary and it'll tell you
right here views how many views are my
videos getting and uh the interesting
thing is it goes from 600 to 1k to 1k
but i guess it's like one point
something thousand
so right now i'm hovering about one and
a half thousand views per day
and um it's do it's going pretty well
it's doing pretty steadily and i'll get
more into that in a second over on the
right hand side you'll have my videos
and the percent of total views and the
attention
and down here is your demographics which
can be actually quite interesting to
look at and on the right hand side your
popularity in certain countries so all
the way up here in the left hand side is
basically
how you navigate through the different
parts of the youtube insight if i scroll
down here to views by clicking on it
it'll give you a number of things
including a graph of your youtube views
if you've ever
gone to google and watched a stock
you'll know that this is a very similar
graph down here you can click this and
drag to a longer period of time and
you'll see
my views have changed a lot since and in
the past
uh six months in the past about four
months i've been on youtube i've gotten
a pretty steady number of views
now on the right hand side you'll see a
map and this is kind of like a density
map with the density of your viewership
you'll be able to see that a whole lot
of my viewers are in the united states
uh and a lot of them are in canada and a
lot in the uk and a few more in brazil
and australia etc in order to view the
viewership for a certain country you can
click on the country canada for example
and it'll switch the graph to see
exactly how many views have been from
that country i've been hovering around
100 150. so let's go back to all
countries just by clicking that
i'm going to scroll down a little bit
here and show you my top videos because
this is really my favorite part um i did
a tutorial on downloading and installing
safari 4.0 beta when it first came out
and that was the first video on youtube
about safari 4 beta and it got about 16
17 000 views
and since then the the final version of
safari 4 has come out but the
instructions for installation have
remained the same so i just changed the
title and added an annotation letting
you know the same instructions applied
and it's hit it's become one of my most
viewed videos that's actually my most
viewed video as 25 of my total video
views in the last six months
uh so la now if we scroll up here to the
demographics section if we click on that
that is basically the the age and gender
of your viewers so most of my viewers
are under the age of 65 a little creepy
but yeah um most of my viewers are
between 13 and 24 i'd say and uh the
vast majority of my viewers are male so
i guess a shout out to my female viewers
and over on the left hand side there is
a community button and this is a pretty
cool uh this is a pretty cool feature of
youtube it'll let you know the community
engagement in your videos so if i scroll
down to the past month
uh you can view total community
engagement in terms of ratings
that's a lot of good ratings and in
terms of comments
and a lot more comments in ratings and
in terms of favorites people who have
favorited my videos which goes up and
down
also you can uh choose ratings per view
by just hitting that ratings per view
button and you can choose average
ratings and see your average ratings
over here so my average rating has been
hovering just over 4.0 which which rocks
it's really awesome that you guys rate
my videos so highly and by the way write
this video five stars yay
so uh we can always um go down and find
another statistic like comments and find
out how many comments per view if it's
close to one i'd be surprised but if you
go ahead and click comments review it'll
let you know that
and the graph obviously has to refresh
every time uh so i think that's views
per comment and then we have to scroll
down to favorites and see our favorites
per view
and that'll be of course a lower number
but my tutorials again they get a
certain amount of views depending on
what time i upload them
now uh down here you'll see what
countries are most active in rating
commenting and subscribing to your
channel so if i go to ratings i'm just
going to go to ratings most of the
people who rate my videos are from the
united states and from the uk
and then here are the list of the
smaller countries uh the smaller number
of viewers and raiders
of my videos and then we'll go over to
the left-hand side and see percent of
community engagement
so it's pretty cool that youtube does
give you this feature uh if we go back
to the summary here it's really cool
that they let you see all those types of
stuff about your youtube account and you
really get a good a good grasp of what
you want to send to a company when
letting them know of your viewership so
uh thanks for watching guys please post
a video response of your uh your youtube
insight i want to see you know what's
your most popular video what's your
demographic look like uh maybe you can
get a little information about how to
improve your videos from that anyway
this has been marcus brownlee from mkbhd
thanks for watching thanks for rating
and commenting and most of all thanks
for subscribing to my videos it really
means a lot thanks for watching guys
peace